Buenos días la eurocámara como
comentabas ha votado una ley pionera que
regula por primera vez en el mundo la
Inteligencia artificial el parlamento
europeo con esta votación que ha
obtenido 499 votos a favor y tan solo 28
en contra prohibido de forma
generalizada la vigilancia masiva
sistemas de vigilancia en que se pueden
elaborar perfiles de personas a través
de sus caras en las calles algo que está
en algunos países como por ejemplo china
esto de forma generalizada estará
prohibido también se regulará los
conocidos Como deepfakes esta tecnología
que genera imágenes falsas o
distorsionadas esto también los
desarrolladores tendrán que determinar y
explicar que se trata de una tecnología
que ha utilizado Deep fake también hace
mención a los chats en los que se exige
una mayor transparencia en que se
exigirá por ejemplo que siempre que se
utilice esta tecnología también se
especifique
riesgo una serie de sistemas que
utilizan la Inteligencia artificial
porque por ejemplo los sistemas que
utilizan por ejemplo las entidades
bancarias para supervisar y para saber
la solvencia de una persona por lo tanto
tampoco se podrá utilizar esta
Inteligencia artificial si se vulneran
los derechos fundamentales con la
votación de hoy las instituciones
europeas ya podrán empezar a negociar
con el resto de países de la Unión
Europea esta ley aún así no podrá
entregar en vigor hasta el próximo 2026